WE ARE IN CHARGE.
THAT’S THE REAL MESSAGE HERE, IN
CASE YOU MISSED IT.
CHRIS HAHN, A RADIO HOST, AND
AGE INTO CHUCK SCHUMER, HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
I KNOW THAT YOU DO NOT LIKE A
TRUMP.
THAT IS FINE.
BUT SPEAK SLOWLY SO THAT I CAN
UNDERSTAND.
EXPLAIN TO ME WHY PAYING OFF
SOMEONE WHO IS EXTORTING YOU,
THREATENING TO MAKE PUBLIC
DETAILS OF YOUR PERSONAL LIFE,
WHY PAYING THAT PERSON IS A
FELONY?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE DO NOT KNOW
THAT THERE WAS ACTUAL EXTORTION.
WE KNOW THAT A PAYMENT WAS MADE,
THERE WAS A CATCH AND KILL DEAL
WITH THE "NATIONAL ENQUIRER,"
WHETHER IT WAS EXTORTION HAS NOT
BEEN PROVEN YET.
NOR HAS IT BEEN ALLEGED IN MANY
CASES BY THE PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: LET ME JUST STOP
AND SAY, I AM ALLEGING IT
BECAUSE IT IS OBVIOUS.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO PAY 100
GRAND OR 150, 200 GRAND TO
SOMEONE UNLESS THERE IS A THREAT
TO YOU AND YOUR REPUTATION.
THIS IS EXTORTION.
I DON’T KNOW WHY IT IS NOT BEING
PROSECUTED.
I DO NOT KNOW WHY TRUMP IS NOT
TO DEFENDING HIMSELF, BUT IT
CLEARLY IS EXTORTION.
WHY IS IT A CRIME TO PAY OFF
SOMEONE WHO YOU HAD AN AFFAIR
WITH?
>> THEY WANT TO TELL A STORY
THAT HE DOES NOT WANT TO HOLD,
HE SAYS, JUST TELL IT TO MEAN, I
FOR IT.
>> Tucker: THAT IS EXTORTION.
IF I DID THAT TO YOU, I SAID I
KNOW IN DETAIL ABOUT YOUR SEX
LIFE, CHRIS HAHN, AND I WILL
TELL IT ON TELEVISION UNLESS YOU
PAY ME.
THAT IS EXTORTION.
BUT WHY IS IT A FELONY TO PAY
WOMEN YOU HAVE HAD RELATIONSHIPS
WITH?
>> IT IS NOT A FELONY, IT IS A
FELONY TO DO A CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURE, AND NOT DISCLOSE
IT.
>> Tucker: HOUSE AT A CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURE?
>> HE MADE THIS DURING THE
CAMPAIGN FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
CAMPAIGN, THERE ARE TAPE
RECORDINGS OF HIM DISCUSSING
THIS WITH MICHAEL COHEN.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, WAIT, IT
IS NOT A SMALL THING, IT IS THE
THING.
THIS IS A CRIME THAT A
"NEW YORK TIMES" TOLD US ON
SATURDAY FEDERAL PROSECUTORS ARE
ALLEGING THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED.
IT IS A FELONY.
A SPECIES OF THIS.
AND MICHAEL COHEN PLED GUILTY TO
SO I JUST WANT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
WHY IS THAT A CONTRIBUTION TO
PAY OFF A FORMER GIRLFRIEND?
I’M HONESTLY CONFUSED.
YOU ARE A CAMPAIGN GUY.
TELL ME.
>> THERE IS A -- THAT HE --
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, I DON’T
KNOW.
>> THERE IS A LOT MORE TO THIS
THAN JUST PAYING OFF.
>> Tucker: ONE ALLEGATION AT A
TIME.
SO FEDERAL PROSECUTORS, THIS IS
NOT JUST SOMETHING THAT DUMB
PEOPLE ON TV ARE TALKING ABOUT
COMING EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
PROSECUTORS IN NEW YORK STATE
ARE SAYING THAT THEY HAVE
APPARENTLY EVIDENCE TO INDICT
OVER.
SO TELL ME WHY, BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON PAY OFF
THEIR GIRLFRIENDS INCLUDING A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN CONGRESS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN CONGRESS.
INCLUDING SOME DEMOCRATS, JUST
THROWING THAT OUT THERE.
SO TELL ME THAT WHILE -- WHY IT
IS A CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION TO
PAY OFF YOUR GIRLFRIEND?
>> I THINK THE FUND THAT
CONGRESS IS USING TO PAY PEOPLE
OFF NEEDS TO BE DISCLOSED.
IN THE MEMBERS WHO ARE INVOLVED
WITH THOSE DISCLOSURE DECISIONS
NEED TO BE REMOVED.
>> I’M SURE THAT THAT WILL
HAPPEN RIGHT AWAY.
MSNBC WILL PUSH REALLY HARD FOR
THAT.
OKAY.
SO TELL ME WHY IT IS A
CAMPAIGN -- CODE THIS IS A
CENTRAL QUESTION, WHY IS IT --
WHY IS THAT A CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION, DID NOT GO TO THE
CAMPAIGN, IT WAS A THREAT TO HIS
REPUTATION AND HIS LIVELIHOOD AS
ALL EXTORTION IS, RIGHT?
SO WHY IS THAT A CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION?
>> THERE IS BLACK LETTER LAW, WE
FIND THESE LAWS PRETTY CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN AND CANNOT DO
WITH FUNDS.
THESE WERE NOT NECESSARILY FROM
TRUMP’S OWN POCKET.
THERE WERE AS ALL SORTS OF
SCHEMES PUT TOGETHER BY THE
PRESIDENT AND MICHAEL COHEN TO
MOVE THE MONEY AROUND SO THAT IT
WAS NOT TRACED BACK TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SPIRO NO, NO, STOP, STOP, STOP.
MAY BE, WE HAVE NEVER HAD A
PRESIDENT LIKE TRUMP AND A
MILLION DIFFERENT WAYS, I AM NOT
DEFENDING HIS PERSONAL LIFE, I
AM MERELY SAYING THAT THIS IS
NOW BEING DESCRIBED AS A FELONY,
AS A CRIME FOR WHICH THE
PRESIDENT COULD BE REMOVED, SO
NOW IS THE TIME WHERE WE NEED TO
BE VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT THE
CRIME IS, BECAUSE YOU HAVE
STOPPED ALL BUSINESS OF
GOVERNMENT SO THAT WE CAN
RESPOND TO THIS, SO LET’S
RESPOND RIGHT NOW, TELL ME HOW
AND WHERE IN CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAW IT SAYS YOU
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO USE YOUR
MONEY, THERE IS NO ALLEGATION
THAT THIS IS CAMPAIGN MONEY.
YOUR MONEY TO PAY OFF A FORMER
GIRLFRIEND?
>> IT IS -- THE ALLEGATION IS
NOT THAT IT IS HIS MONEY, THERE
IS ALLEGATIONS THAT HE MOVE
MONEY AROUND FROM VARIOUS
SCHEMES.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE ALLOWED TO
DO THAT TOO.
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO HIDE THE
PAYMENTS.
IS THAT A CRIME NOW?
BECAUSE IT IS YOUR MONEY?
>> THAT IS A VIOLATION -- A
CLEAR VIOLATION OF CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAW PART.
>> Tucker: I WILL LET YOU
SPEAK, WE ARE IN CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAW THAT TAKING MONEY
THAT IS NOT PREMIER POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN TO RESPOND TO AN
EXTORTION ATTEMPT TO PAY OFF
YOUR GIRLFRIEND OR PAY THE
GARDENER, PAY ANYBODY, WHY IS
THAT A FELONY?
WHERE DOES IT SAY THAT?
>> CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAW, I WILL
NOT QUOTE TO THE SECTION IN
VERSE, I DO NOT KNOW IT OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD.
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAW CLEARLY
STATES THAT ANY MONEY SPENT FOR
CAMPAIGN PURPOSES SPECIFICALLY
BY PEOPLE OTHER THAN THE
CANDIDATE MUST BE DISCLOSED.
>> Tucker: WHY IS THAT IT
CAMPAIGN PURPOSE PAY TO SPEAK OF
THE PRESIDENT AND MICHAEL COHEN
WHEN CLEARLY SET UP THE SCHEME
SO THAT OTHER PEOPLE COULD PAY
THESE WOMEN OFF ON BEHALF OF
DONALD TRUMP WHILE HE WAS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AND
THE ALLOCATIONS WITHIN HIS
CAMPAIGN AND HIS REPUTATION.
THAT IS A VIOLATION.
>> Tucker: NO, ACTUALLY,
BECAUSE ANYBODY FACED, I DON’T
KNOW A SINGLE MAN WHO FACES THAT
ALLEGATION WHO THOUGHT THAT HE
COULD SQUELCH IT WOULD NOT PAID
THE PERSON OFF.
BECAUSE IT DOES INCALCULABLE
DAMAGE TO YOUR REPUTATION
WHETHER YOU ARE RUNNING FOR
ANYTHING OR NOT.
SO IT IS SO CLEARLY NOT A
CAMPAIGN VIOLATION THAT I WONDER
IF WE WANT TO SET THIS
PRECEDENT.
DO YOU WANT TO LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE PEOPLE PAYING OFF
EXTORTION ATTEMPTS ARE NOW
CAMPAIGN FINANCE FELONS?
THIS IS LUNACY, AND YOU KNOW IT.
>> THIS IS STRIKINGLY SIMILAR TO
WHAT HAPPENED TO JOHN EDWARDS
PRETTY >> Tucker: YES, AND IT
IS AWFUL WHAT HAPPENED TO JOHN
EDWARDS.
>> THIS IS STRUGGLING SIMILAR
SITUATION.
AND WHAT HAPPENED --
>> Tucker: AND OTHER POPULIST
WITH HIS B.S. CAMPAIGN FINANCE
NONSENSE.
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
>> THE CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAW, IT
IS MORE THAN THAT, IT IS A
FOREIGN CORRUPT PRACTICES ACT.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A SEPARATE
TAKING.